representantes nacionales y de
organismos internacionales señoras y
señores el 75 aniversario de las
naciones unidas no se encuentra
nuevamente en medio de la crisis
de distintas características sin duda a
la catástrofe provocada por la segunda
guerra mundial pero que también nos
obliga a repensar nuestro futuro para
consolidar los logros alcanzados y
también prevenir futuras crisis sean
éstas económicas sanitarias climáticas o
todas ellas en su conjunto
la dimensión de la actual pandemia y las
penosas consecuencias en pérdidas de
vida y afecciones a la salud de muchas
personas concentra nuestra atención
pues se torna necesario procurar
soluciones para nuestros pueblos
especialmente para aquellas personas más
vulnerables y más expuestas a sufrir las
consecuencias de esta pandemia de modo
grave en la salud como también a sus
modos y medios de vida
pero la conmemoración de este
aniversario debe interpelarnos también
sobre el futuro que queremos para
nuestros países y nuestras sociedades
más allá de esta crisis
y esas esta asamblea general del señor
presidente que desea enfatizar una vez
más que el camino a recorrer tanto para
la salida de esta pandemia como durante
los próximos 75 años nos van a encontrar
siempre del mismo lado del
multilateralismo apoyando la búsqueda de
soluciones que estén amparadas en marcos
jurídicos multilaterales en todos los
aspectos de la vida internacional salud
medioambiente comercio migración
la adhesión del uruguay hace pocos meses
a la alianza por el multilateralismo
iniciativa en defensa del orden
multilateral lanzada por alemania y
francia- es sólo una muestra más del
compromiso de nuestro país con esta
causa
señor presidente uruguay apoya el rol de
la organización mundial de la salud y el
papel del sistema de las naciones unidas
para coordinar la respuesta global a
esta pandemia en el entendimiento que
las organizaciones internacionales
cumplen un rol fundamental de
coordinación y orientación mediante el
cual deberían encontrarse las mejores
soluciones posibles a la crítica
situación actual y un manejo coordinado
de los impactos de esta a mediano y
largo plazo
mi país señor presidente ha adherido a
los llamados para asegurar un acceso
mundial y equitativo a las tecnologías
en el área de la salud a los
medicamentos y las vacunas a través de
mancomunar los conocimientos la
propiedad intelectual y los datos
necesarios para la detección prevención
tratamiento y respuesta al cob en 19
la respuesta de nuestro país a la
pandemia se ha centrado un abordaje
multidisciplinario social económico y
epidemiológico monitoreado por un grupo
asesor científico en horario que nos
genera mucho orgullo y basado en el uso
de la libertad en forma responsable por
parte de nuestros ciudadanos con
solidaridad y generosidad lo que esto
sumado a un sistema de salud fuerte y
con resiliencia nos ha permitido retomar
las entidades laborales educativas y
culturales
también queremos hacer aquí un llamado a
la comunidad internacional
para que la actual pandemia no derive en
un debilitamiento del cumplimiento de
los compromisos asumidos a nivel
multilateral
debemos evitar caer en escenarios de
nacionalismos y proteccionismos que de
alguna manera perjudican las relaciones
internacionales en el comercio
internacional o interrumpan las cadenas
de abastecimiento y a la propia
circulación de suministros médicos que
son tan necesarios para la salida de
esta crisis sanitaria
en el comienzo de la década de acción
para la consecución de los objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible pasar de la
palabra a la acción será una condición
necesaria para poner fin a la pobreza
proteger el medio ambiente y mejorar las
condiciones de vida de la población
mundial
las naciones unidas han promovido la
agenda 2030 y esta debe mantenerse pese
a las importantes dificultades actuales
como la guía central a procurar para
avanzar en el desarrollo todo es
sostenible
uruguay ha trabajado arduamente desde su
aprobación para lograr un efectivo
cumplimiento nuestro país continúa
honrando su historia en materia de
reducción de desigualdades así como en
su apuesta por el trabajo digno
sustentado en la inversión y el
crecimiento
nuestro gobierno ha asumido asimismo un
compromiso ineludible en materia de
educación en todos los niveles tan
necesarios para la plena realización del
ser humano y para que todos los
ciudadanos tengan las mismas
oportunidades
esta pandemia global ha evidenciado que
ante desafíos siempre cambiantes es
importante mantener las condiciones y
apoyos necesarios de la cooperación
internacional para que todos los estados
y en particular los países en vías de
desarrollo
podamos avanzar hacia el desarrollo
sostenible
en este escenario resulta paradójico que
países como uruguay clasificados como
países en desarrollo de altos ingresos
no tengan acceso a la mayor parte de las
fuentes de cooperación internacional o
líneas más favorables de crédito es por
ello que continuaremos promoviendo la
revisión de dicha clasificación o
graduación que se basa
solamente en el ingreso per cápita para
que estas categorías sean realmente
adecuadas y equitativas debería de
considerarse un criterio
multidimensional para definir los grados
de desarrollo y las necesidades de apoyo
internacional de cada país en base a su
realidad
en este sentido deseo subrayar el apoyo
de la cepal en favor del desarrollo de
un criterio multifactorial
para el desarrollo sostenible no será
tal si no nos preocupamos por el cuidado
del medio ambiente y ese también al
igual que la pandemia es un reto al que
los países no pueden hacer frente en
solitario sino que requiere de la
voluntad colectiva para enfrentar los
retos que se presenta la humanidad
uruguay continúa dando pasos en ese
sentido con la reciente creación de un
ministerio de ambiente como muestra de
la prioridad que esa temática tiene para
el gobierno
señor presidente uruguaya se ha
manifestar aquí una vez más su apoyo al
acuerdo de parís en materia de cambio
climático y su compromiso firme con los
objetivos trazados en esa materia
uruguay ha desarrollado un sistema
nacional de respuesta al cambio
climático que atiende la prevención de
sus riesgos a su mitigación y a la
adaptación de este
entendemos que los esfuerzos provechosos
las buenas experiencias y las gestiones
efectivas y eficientes sujetas a
rendición de cuentas frente a desafíos
actuales deberían ser objetivos de mayor
atención y reconocimiento
celebramos también la realización de la
cumbre so biodiversidad que tendrá lugar
la semana próxima y manifestamos nuestro
compromiso para promover estrategias y
prácticas de uso sostenible de la
diversidad biológica y los recursos
naturales desarrollando mecanismos para
su mejor gestión y su mejor uso
mi país quiere reforzar aquí en esta
asamblea su apoyo al mapa de ruta el
secretario general sobre cooperación
digital
uruguay entiende que para que estas
iniciativas prosperen y contribuyan
efectivamente al cumplimiento de los eau
de ese se requiere que las tecnologías
digitales permitan superar la brecha
digital y de conectividad también tanto
en países como también dentro de cada
país asimismo resulta imprescindible
promover el respeto de los derechos
humanos en las redes la protección de la
privacidad y los datos personales así
como el acceso a la información y la
libertad de expresión tanto pública como
privada finalmente es necesario trabajar
en materia de seguridad digital con una
amplia participación de actores
estatales sector privado y sociedad
civil
haciendo referencia a las iniciativas
del secretario general quisiera
detenerme por un momento en su llamado a
un cese al fuego un cese al fuego global
endosado por mi país un entorno pacífico
es indispensable para hacer frente a la
pandemia por eso debemos en estos
momentos redoblar la apuesta por el
diálogo la resolución de controversias
por medios pacíficos el estado de
derecho para poder aliviar el
sufrimiento y llevar esperanza a todas
las poblaciones vulnerables
mi país está fuertemente comprometido
con las fuerzas de paz de naciones
unidas siendo uno de los principales
contribuyentes de tropa per cápita a
nivel mundial una clara demostración de
este compromiso nacional en la oferta
formulada por nuestro gobierno para
instalar un laboratorio para aumentar
las capacidades diagnóstico médico en
las operaciones de paz de las naciones
unidas en el marco de esta pandemia en
este contexto vale la pena recordar los
reclamos de uruguay en la defensa de
hospitales y escuelas objeto de ataques
en las zonas de conflicto y la necesidad
de apoyar las resoluciones del consejo
de seguridad en esta materia
uruguay reitera el compromiso nacional
con la agenda de derechos humanos y
continuará agregando activamente por la
defensa de estos incluyendo la
protección y los derechos del niño la
situación de los civiles en situaciones
de conflicto y los derechos de la mujer
y por el respeto de los mismos por parte
de los actores de la comunidad
internacional
en este contexto continuaremos velando
por la aplicación efectiva de los
mecanismos de defensa de estos derechos
por parte de las naciones unidas'
especial mención queremos hacer a la
existencia de sectores vulnerables de la
población particularmente afectados por
la pandemia tales como las mujeres
víctimas violencia doméstica problemas
de especial preocupación para uruguay y
que nos ha impulsado a desarrollar
políticas específicas para dar
respuestas a esta situación
y no podemos olvidar a los migrantes y
desplazados internos que también son
doblemente vulnerables a esta pandemia
destacamos aquí una vez más la política
abierta de nuestro país como receptor de
inmigración voluntaria basada en los
valores democracia igualdad ante la ley
y el respeto de los derechos de todas
las personas independientemente de su
origen señor presidente a través del
fortalecimiento de los derechos humanos
no sólo se avanzará en la protección
sino que se logrará además el
empoderamiento de quienes están llamados
a ser actores fundamentales en la
construcción de la paz y el desarrollo y
hablo de las mujeres y de los jóvenes
finalmente quisiera destacar el papel de
la corte penal internacional y la
importancia de su efecto disuasorio
contra los genocidios y atrocidades en
masa y sus perpetradores
uruguay reitera su compromiso con el
sistema de justicia internacional y en
particular su apoyo a la corte penal
internacional como institución judicial
independiente e imparcial con un rol
central en la lucha contra la impunidad
y la búsqueda de justicia
en este foro en el que se selló la paz
hace 75 años deseo manifestar mi
preocupación por los peligros que se
plantean ante el incumplimiento de los
acuerdos de desarme o el retiro de
algunas partes de los mismos lo que
puede derivar en la reanudación de
carreras armamentistas que nos
retrotraen a una época en el que mundo
vivía bajo la sombra de un posible
conflicto nuclear
no se concibe paz en el mundo si no
existen compromisos serios por parte de
la comunidad internacional en materia de
desarme y no proliferación
preocupa a la región y a mi país la
proliferación y tráfico ilícito de armas
pequeñas y ligeras que representan una
amenaza para la estabilidad de las
regiones y para la seguridad global
alimentan el crimen y la inseguridad y
afectan la convivencia pacífica dentro
de las sociedades nuestro gobierno se ha
comprometido a combatir la inseguridad y
la delincuencia y trabajaremos
arduamente para ello también
continuaremos cooperando con las
naciones unidas en la lucha contra el
terrorismo el crimen transnacional
organizado y los vínculos entre ambos
señor presidente el futuro que queremos
para nuestros pueblos es uno de los que
podamos avanzar asociaciones comunes y
solidarias ante los desafíos que se
presenten para alcanzar un desarrollo
sostenible e inclusivo donde se respeten
los derechos de todos y se ofrezcan
oportunidades para el desarrollo de
todos y cada uno de los ciudadanos de
este mundo sin dejar a nadie atrás
queremos un futuro en paz
un mundo en que los estados apostemos al
diálogo y la negociación en el que
encontremos salidas a los conflictos
actuales que contemplen los derechos de
todas las partes para eso necesitamos
redoblar la apuesta por la diplomacia
preventiva y la mediación como la
privación de conflictos
para ello necesitamos unas naciones
unidas- que actúen más coordinadamente
tanto en el discurso como en la práctica
una organización que se relacione
activamente con otras organizaciones
internacionales incluidas las
financieras para ser capaces de
implementar una diversidad de mecanismos
que permitan a los países superar los
obstáculos externos e internos para su
desarrollo contemplando la
multidimensionalidad del mismo
interesa especialmente uruguay
incrementar la relevancia del accionar
general de las naciones unidas y en
particular de su asamblea general así
como que todos sus estados miembros
tengan posibilidades de participación
efectiva
uruguay ha procurado siempre aportar a
la transparencia general del
funcionamiento de la organización de las
naciones unidas y de todos sus órganos
incluidos los trabajos del consejo
nación de seguridad de las naciones
unidas
en los tiempos que corren se valorarán
las posibilidades de aumentar la
eficacia y eficiencia de la organización
al tiempo de contener los costos
económicos de funcionamiento y aumentar
la transparencia y la rendición de
cuentas de sus gastos valoramos
especialmente los esfuerzos del
organismo para incluir a la sociedad
civil y el sector privado como parte de
la solución a las problemáticas
económicas sociales y ambientales que se
presenten ya que un desarrollo inclusivo
y sostenible requiere de la
participación de toda la sociedad los
líderes del mundo deben estar a la
altura de las circunstancias y de
nuestros pueblos y ser capaces al igual
que lo fueron nuestros líderes hace 75
años de pensar más allá de la actual
crisis y consolidar los mecanismos e
instrumentos multilaterales que
posibiliten a nuestras sociedades
alcanzar un desarrollo sostenible e
inclusivo respetando la democracia
a las libertades y los derechos de todos
los seres humanos los líderes del mundo
debemos hacernos caros muchas gracias